hello everybody my name is nya and i'm
the black female engineer
i provide content for new and aspiring
software engineers
and today we're going to be talking
about what the software engineering
interview process
looks like now this is going to be more
of a conversation
i do have tips as to how to go about
certain interviews and
job hunt tips and things like that i'll
link those above and
in the description box below but this is
going to be more of a talkative
video so anyway let's get to it
so you already applied to a job
congratulations because that in itself
is a grueling process so congrats on
sending out those resumes
make sure you're tracking the amount of
applications you're sending out i'll
have my job tracker in the description
box
below free to download free to use just
follow the instructions
and hopefully that helps with that
tracking but
okay what comes next this
is all from my experience it's not you
know law it's not
it's different for everybody but this
was my experience
so typically within two to
five weeks is when i would hear back
from a company
i would hear back on whether i got you
know an interview
or whether i you know just didn't get
the job
within that time frame usually now
just you know a little note over here
don't be discouraged
by seeing constant rejections
for interviews y'all once i
when i say once i mean just a few months
ago when i was applying i
got a rejection notification
two hours after i had applied to that
job
i was like wow what could i have
possibly said
that this person was just like not this
she is not the one boom so just
remember that and just keep your head up
but typically yes between two and five
weeks is when i would hear back
about some type of update now let's say
i got an interview
what how this typically looked was
i would get an email from a recruiter
asking me um for to validate certain
information
validate the location i was applying to
or the location i live
in just like things like that and so
typically
once i got this email i knew
that i was being considered and they're
just you know crossing their teeth and
all of that
one of two things happened i either
would get asked for a
very quick phone um conversation
it's still an interview i tweeted
everything like an interview like
all of it but you know more of like a
conversation about 15 to 20 minutes
where the recruiter learns more about me
and my background and i learned more
about the
you know opportunity either that or
i would get sent a hacker ring challenge
now what is hackering
hacker inc is a resource that companies
use to administer
coding challenges to applicants it's the
way that they try to assess
um in applicant skill sets now you know
i have my own opinions on technical
interviews and things like that but yes
that is how they typically went about
that so one of these two things would
happen
so let's start with this round i get an
email
asking for availability for a 10 to 20
15 to 20 minute conversation i would
then set up
that meeting conversation slash
interview
with that interviewer via google you
know calendar and all of that
and when we would start talking it would
be more you know behavioral in
um in structure seeing where
my background is learning more about my
projects and
my interests going forward those are
typically the main three topics
seeing my transition into software
engineering because i had transitioned
from a different career
so hearing that story and then hearing
about
what tech stack um i prefer
if i'm interested in learning more um
and just like my learning style um and
coding style
and then what i am looking for in a
company
and so those are really the main three
things they hit every single time
now if they liked what they heard within
a week of that i would get notice of if
i can
have a second interview slash of you
know
next really formal longer interview
about
30 to 45 minutes up to an hour
and so this interview would really dive
into do i know definitions do i
understand what oop
is do i understand what agile
development looks like or the software
development life cycle
really just proving that i know my stuff
especially because
i didn't get a computer science degree
really
them honing into that now if they liked
what they heard
there then i would be invited for a
technical
interview this technical interview would
typically be a live interview
where i would be given a challenge
right on the spot something like i can't
even think one something like you know
loops and working with arrays and
objects in javascript
i typically would be able to pick my
coding language so i always chose
javascript
and yeah them saying how do you solve
this and then
i talk through it and you know walk
through my solution
and then try to handle anything they
throw
at me i would get between one and two
questions of this
and then after that typically then it
was it
that was it and i would hear back
from the company in about
like a week to ten days after that so
the whole process
after getting that initial invite that
initial interview
would take about four weeks
max that's typically how things went but
then it already had taken
two to five weeks and two is rare
typically about four weeks
for me to even hear back on that status
of my application
to begin with so overall it would be
about an
eight week process
for that one job now let's say we go
into
the other section the other of the two
paths we could have chosen where
i right off the bat was given a hacker
ring
challenge right for my application they
sent me a hackering challenge
even this this is something they don't
do to everybody so if you get a
challenge
don't think oh like they do this to
everybody it doesn't mean anything like
no
that means a lot actually because you
already have beat out a significant
amount of applicants
if you even get that first challenge so
no
be proud of yourself for that and know
that you are
in the running to be a part of this
company so
we get the hackering challenge and i
would typically have about
one and a half to two hours to complete
the challenge
now that sounds like a lot yo it is
nothing it is nothing no time at all
like the amount of times i have ran out
the clock
is insane so you think it's
like oh wow like that's so much time
like i'll do it in just a few minutes
like
like maybe you will you know like i'm
not saying you won't but
just know that time will fly
and you'll look up and be like how do i
only have five minutes left
and in my case like how do i have five
minutes and i've completed 10
10 of the problem
that's a sort of a different day so
doing this hacker rank
really just trying to make sure you
answer all the questions hacker rank um
has up
the company typically from my
understanding typically chooses the
questions
um it asks for and tells you
this is what your solution should look
like and so you're just
working trying to figure it out you can
typically i typically worked on my own
ide
unless it explicitly said that i
couldn't
then i would work specifically in hacker
inc but
during this you typically couldn't you
know google anything
ask a friend call a friend you couldn't
do any of that again i would say it in
the challenge that you can't do these
things
i have had challenges sent where it
explicitly said that i could
which you think is a good thing but and
but then you realize it said that
because it knows
that there is no resource out there that
can help you so
might as well you know waste your time
you know
googling the x y and z and so that's why
it would do that looking back that is
typically the only times it would say
you can search things
but anyway so do this hacker rank one
and a half two hours gone
present prescend and within
hacker rings were rough in terms of
knowing when i'd hear back that was
more of a shake up i could hear back
anywhere from three days after
to three weeks after once i didn't hear
back
from a company after i submitted my
hacking until like three months later
and they're like oh do you want an
interview and i'm like
no like that ship has
sailed like no keep your interview like
i
i was just like really like and it was a
company that um
was one i admired very much too and so
like when i saw that it kind of just
ruined my day i was like are you serious
are you sick but anyway anyway
so anywhere from three days to a couple
of
weeks i would honestly prepare for
something like two and a half to three
weeks i think that would
really be the average i would see and
depending on how you did you would
either get an automated message saying
sorry we decided to go to with other
applicants or
then we would go to a behavioral
interview which was about 30 to 45
minutes
and then a technical interview typically
another technical interview and then
see if you can offer so the two
routes you know were very similar except
one you know
started with a hack rank or one started
with a very quick
10 15 20 minute conversation but after
that
it kind of went through um the same way
i would always prepare by practicing
behavioral
and technical interview questions i
actually have like a 10-page
document filled with interview questions
and answers that i would type in
um and just practice those and i'll you
know what i'll link those questions
below
i'm trying to think of the questions i
believe yeah i'll link those questions
below
because you know hopefully it provides
you with some type of starting point at
least
for what you should look at but it's
very very comprehensive and so
if you don't know certain things don't
freak out or anything there's still some
things on there that i was never able to
answer
um but it just provides you with like if
you can't answer like
at even like 50 of these you are in a
very good spot
so i'll link that down below um so you
know it's free to use for you to
download just follow the
instructions looking back i wouldn't
really say there was anything i would
change
other than my attitude i think
anyone who knows me knows i am just a
warrior like crazy
especially because i'm such a planner
because i want to just
you know be prepared for anything that i
would just like this whole process
was just not good to be honest for like
my own mental well-being
um and so if i could go back i wish i
had that attitude of you know what if
you want me you want me if you don't you
don't like
life goes on um because honestly that's
what it is like
even if you know you're self-taught even
if you're coming at this from coding
boot camp
or you know a computer science degree
people
are going to find good and bads from all
of these things
all of them nothing just qualifies you
off the badge just everywhere
and nothing is just good everywhere
people are going to find
something to be like no actually this is
bad because x y and z
or actually we wanted someone who had
more x y and z or less x y and z like
at the end of the day i am who i am and
honestly
i would treat and i don't need to roll
your eyes at this because i would have
rolled my eyes
if if i watched a video that said this
but i would treat that as like a
blessing like i saw this
there's this quote um that's like
you can ask someone of something and two
things
one of two things will happen they'll
either oblige and give that thing to you
or they'll admit that they can't give it
to you and walk away
both are blessings and this is something
that
i would apply to interviewing job hunts
as well because
if a company doesn't want you then it
means that it would have
been a company that even if you were
hired there that you would not have been
happy in because maybe they're too
you know too like buttoned up and stern
and
old school or they're too like out there
unprofessional and all over the place or
you'd have way too many duties or
not enough duties and things like that
so
honestly treat it as a blessing that a
company is not wasting your time
of bringing you through this process
when they know
that you are not the person for their
culture for their atmosphere and things
like that
again it's so much easier to say this
now so i
really just am not treating this lightly
but at the end of the day you
are who you are your journey is your
journey and you must own that
and if a company does not like that to
like okay
buy but a company will like that and
that is the company
that will truly value you as a
professional and as a person
and that is where you'll hopefully end
up really truly being happy
so that's my ted talk for the day y'all
but no
i hope this video just allowed some
insight of what to expect once you start
your job hunt or
if you've just started and are in that
you know limbo stage of waiting
to hear back from things and all of that
so if you have questions for you know
interviewing
or any of that please comment below like
i hope you've seen by now that i
really love to interact with you all um
you can also interact
with me on instagram so please let me
know
and i'll see y'all later bye